gone are the sounds of conflict at least
for now
a truth in einel Halloween lebanon's
largest camp for Palestinian refugees is
holding after four days of intense
factional fighting the Lebanese Army
which operates checkpoints around the
camp that doesn't intervene in security
matters has reopened the entrances a
welcome respite for the tens of
thousands of people trapped in what was
in essence an urban Battleground but the
crisis is not over
now the investigation committee will
determine who is responsible for killing
the head of fatah's military in the camp
General Abu Ashraf alamushi and after
they identify the killers need to be
handed over to Lebanese authorities to
face Justice
five for power and dominance the latest
violence involved the fatah movement
Jean de Shem and other armed groups many
homes have been damaged in neighborhoods
which witnessed the heaviest fighting it
was the worst in years
there is no doubt that targeting of
high-ranking Palestinian commander who
was in the charge of security in the
camp was not a coincidence it was a
targeted killing that aimed to cause
chaos in the camp which destabilizes
Security in the country we are doing our
best to solve this politically but some
of the groups involved don't have
political representation which makes it
hard to put pressure on them
and other armed groups have recently
made inroads in the camp challenging the
authority of mainstream Palestinian
factions
military Showdown would be costly as
previous standoffs have
happenings are poor and have nowhere to
go it could take weeks if not months to
win a battle in narrow Alleyways which
means the conflict could spread to areas
outside ainal halwe people here already
have so little they live inside a one
square kilometer walled off area and
they fear a truce is far from a lasting
ceasefire or agreement that will prevent
the recurrence of similar outbreaks of
violence
Southern Lebanon